the French government says it will
firmly support efforts by the West
African Regional group ecowas to
reinstate niger's deposed president West
African nations gave coup leaders until
Sunday to give up power and return to
civilian rule the Region's military
Chiefs have drawn up a plan for possible
military intervention Charles Stratford
reports on the Senegalese Capital Dhaka
strong words from the French foreign
minister as a deadline on niger's coup
leaders approaches
if on Sunday they should still be in
power and we want to believe that they
won't well ecowas as expected will have
to decide which is not to allow a coup
d'etat to take place this is enough this
really is one cool too many
the coup leaders and many of their
supporters want an end to what they say
is French interference in niger's
affairs
protesters have burnt the French flag
during Pro coup rallies and attacked the
French Embassy in yemi
there are an estimated 1500 French
soldiers in Niger there as part of an
International Coalition fighting armed
groups such as isil and Al-Qaeda across
the region
echoas the West African Regional block
says it has a plan for a potential
military intervention in Niger as a last
resort if the coup leaders Do Not Free
deposed president Muhammad bazoom on
Sunday and return to civilian rule this
is the terrible mistake that equality
test of States made in making a threat
and setting a deadline without
consulting their military Chiefs so the
military Chiefs have met they've looked
at the options and they've placed the
intervention at the very last two
supporters in niger's capital remain
defiant
as Nigerians we said to ourselves that
if the military decided to intervene in
this situation we would be with them all
the same and we are determined to go
wherever they want and we are not even
in favor of negotiations Niger belongs
to us yeah diplomatic and mediation
efforts including a visit to Niger by
Chad's transitional president Muhammad
Idris Debbie have so far failed
Chad's defense minister says his country
will not get involved in a potential
ecowas military intervention
we will never intervene with our
military we encourage dialogue we want
stability to come back to Niger the
military leadership in neighboring Mali
and Burkina Faso say any echoas military
involvement in Niger will constitute a
declaration of war on them too
ecos and its International supporters
say efforts continue to try and find a
peaceful solution to the crisis any
military action against niger's coup
leaders poses immense risk armed groups
including Al-Qaeda and Isis taking
advantage of the chaos and a potential
war that could spread right across the
region Charles Stratford Al Jazeera
Dakar
well the French Foreign Ministry has
told out a zero that Paris has committed
to a diplomatic resolution
actually a small group of officer that
had taken into a stage an electric
Democratic democratically elected
president president bazoom they are also
waging a very uh a very dry repression
against Civil Society journalists free
media as well as you know different
political parties that have been
arrested throughout these last week so
this is the situation that the
International Community today is saying
is unacceptable and that's what iku was
has been saying for a week now with the
summit of the heads of stages a week ago
that decided with very strong measures
on the purchase for them to renounce the
coup and hand over a power to the
elected the democratically elected
president president bazoom so as the
International Community said it has a
hole because it's not just France that
actually supports ecowas efforts to go
back to constitutional order it's the US
and the EU the UN with the U.N security
Council that expressed itself just a
week ago to condemn the attempted coup
and support the region in its efforts to
bring back Niger to the Constitutional
order first we have to support ecowas
efforts in the mediation effort that
they have been uh you know doing for the
last few days and you know that there
was a delegation yesterday in Miami led
by the ex-president the former president
and Nigerian president Abdul salami
abubakar who led the delegation in order
to go and speak who is the Buddhist and
led them to the conclusion that they are
actually in an impasse and that they
should end over the the power back to
the elected president so this is the
time we are in at the moment and all
efforts from the International Community
should converge in supporting this
mediation effort